hello and welcome to Z 0 plane I am all
guns blazing sparse cause we're off okay
I do know that guy and he plays the
Queens gambit accepted 96 okay that's so
that is a sideline but what is the
answer Queenie to is it Cooney to 193
okay I'll go I go here I really don't
know and takes rook to e1 I thought okay
I wonder if this is an idea I'm really i
really don't know how it works for
cricket e5
and probably 95 now no doesn't do it
okay huh ok so d5 is probably not good
but this may be that looks ok
controlling t5 and you're having a look
at b7 so they cannot develop that easily
ok so d5 now it takes I can't even take
wait I don't know my takes a knight
takes Bishop takes there should be six
probably
okay but it's Lola this is the move that
make sense in context of what I did
earlier maybe just Bishop e6 here if I
take Queen takes Queen B 7 you will get
compensation I guess but it's hard to
avoid that as I said this is kind of the
only thing making sense in connection
with what I did earlier so let's grab
this my background is weak but don't I
don't see any direct way for him to
exploit that yes this one hmm ok I'm
pusher perform covering the back rank
and looking at b8 it still has to get
this poor bag which probably is possible
with quite a number of moves but the
moment he takes it this is one of them
hmm ok so i think i'll take and now what
this probably are looking at a seven the
danger is that of a black is that you
will still lose that pawn I will see
Bishop f6 i guess i can now take a seven
but he has got Luke a four
yeah that leads nowhere Luke a force is
important of course I can go look d7
rugby 7 to attack the seventh I just do
much either
ok I think I'll take it and it's very
mica I'm probably no alternative
yeah just rotate for assume is doing the
trick not sure why he needed to do that
but probably it's okay still shy now I
might be able to keep the pole and maybe
okay he's got Bishop deform because of
the big back rang hmm yeah he has fun
yeah and I it's look much that I can do
him he's active enough to always draw
that
it doesn't really matter ok I'm going to
draw blood I expected that time morning
check ok to a half a 50-something
seconds
check your so check it check all right
shouldn't really matter check check
check check check check yeah so let's
see if I can win this 30 seconds should
be doable black resigns yeah that's what
you get for playing on time in such a
position at least sometimes you get it
okay job I this is kind of this kind of
players of it minimalistic but it it can
be and it can be interesting playing for
this little development advantage here
with g5 but I guess it's not enough who
should be six is good yeah i came i
think i can always been one of those
pawns but he will get enough activity to
get it back this for example i cannot
cannot develop here this is the thing i
can try this let's say and grab this and
now that's nothing left yeah the game
continuation is actually comparable i'm
getting getting a porn but i don't get
get much maybe this is better actually
this is what the engine is suggesting
yeah that's good because their
background issue is resolved no I
probably don't have enough to do
anything substantial but um you have
ideas to enter here at least it's better
than the game which was just completely
equal j h 5 rupee 7 that was possible h5
was also completely unnecessary okay for
is the obvious draw she somehow didn't
want so h 5 or K root e7 was
sting Jackie well I was I was more or
less okay with this completely drawn
position I could have won a porn yard
that would have been nice check but okay
I had to play somewhat somewhat quickly
because anytime okay yeah there's simply
nothing going on and just wants to win
Oh Timon Jen blunders a check run at the
bishop yeah not very interesting that
that game but at least them I got some
points out of it after he wanted to play
one time okay thanks for watching